[Music]
give me a memory you have from full
screen
so [__] so many
um
where do you want to start
I could start with how I was
so late to my interview because I uh
miscalculated
I thought I was supposed to be there at
like 11 okay and I was supposed to be
there at 10 30 or something right that
was with Anna yep
and uh I had to sit around for hours and
hours until she was free
and then the recruiter
was an [__] to me about it and then
he got fired some Weeks Later damn I was
like dang rip yeah suck it
got hired for that right before I went
to Thailand came back got hired
um
I remember I
would try to duck out of the team
lunches okay because I just I don't know
yeah I would do the same thing I would
do the exact same thing feel really
awkward Cody we're gonna
no I got I brought lunch yeah and they
stopped asking me eventually yeah which
was awesome yeah such a great point to
get to
uh yeah when I ducked out of The A Team
lunch or tried to because I I
legitimately was gonna go to the dentist
she pulls me aside and she goes hey
what do you have to do at lunch let's
reschedule that for another day oh no
because it's important that the team
gets to connect okay yeah you're like I
have crippling nerve pain though
nah I just buckled I was like all right
no you did oh no she was so intentional
about it that I oh no and I was already
you know
I was already
I don't know
in such a place where I'm like yeah you
know I'd [__] I'd see if I could get
away with leaving early I'd like leave
at like 3 30 yeah and work from my
apartment across the way and then run
back if I need to be called into a
meeting yeah no I canceled that I
canceled the dentist damn dude went to
the lunch
it was awkward as [__] yeah was it just
didn't really talk at least it was like
with marketing people
yeah
I think I was the only dude on the team
so
I just you know
I just felt I always felt like maybe I
just shut the [__] up yeah
just let everybody here do their thing
I'm just be right here yeah
other other fun memories of full screen
um our boy Scott which one was he we're
all black did he do back end stuff no no
Scott the
he was like head of Studio stuff oh yeah
yeah
yeah boy
and we had that one joke that we had to
get rid of what was it
yeah and we were like why we're making
fun of
yeah but he was saying that they're
making fun of them yes yeah yes
and he and he was like nah Still Still
bro still
other core memories I have uh
when full screen invested in that series
The deleted with what's his face from
American Horror Story
no no that was a different one no wasn't
it didn't wasn't Logan Paul in that mate
actually he might have been let me look
it up let me look it up
damn dude you know we were standing next
to the creator of American Horror Story
that night that's pretty crazy at that
party that's crazy because that's like a
really successful show right oh yeah
yeah super is it oh no no sorry not the
deleted I thought you were joking about
the deleted yeah no no American Horror
Story is oh we were standing next to
Madeline Brewer they had Nash Grier
they had Amanda Cerny yep yeah it was a
horrible show
it made no [__] sense
it was painful I had pointed out of town
I had to
I had to watch it to come up with
marketing material for it
and I'm like this is just kind of like
softcore I can't speak to the guy's
intentions but definitely felt like he
just got budget and then got a bunch of
like young people he thought were
attractive and then yeah or borderline
it was just a lot of influencer softcore
and there was some weird story behind it
we're watching it at work feeling like I
shouldn't this is like uncomfortable
it's just in that [__] in that open
kitchen area
dude I hated my job
that's why I always bug you guys I'm
like let's go on a three-hour lunch and
we did we would we would do it I'd push
the limit we would we would walk down to
um
it was a burger place is that still
there no no oh what was that piece of
[__] restaurant
it was so bad well we went to True Food
Kitchen a lot yes there was that there
but the the they said horrible the
burger place was like hobby
yeah those burgers were they were all
right didn't you order with like a form
yeah yeah they're right in there yeah
yeah anything you have to order with a
form was is bad yeah horrible like a
Scantron you would like such a mid-2000s
thing yeah like that
remember when that first rolled out it
like bird like when Burger spots were
everywhere yeah you can get anything on
your burger that's not good no what the
the best restaurant is you go in and
there's one option yeah and like we do
this and it's [__] amazing because
we've tested this yeah you don't know
better than us yep we're the ones that
do Burgers yeah we've you know we've
done uh
Decades of user testing this is the one
burger that is better than them all and
I'm like I trust you yeah yeah agree
yeah letting people build Burgers is
psycho yeah stupid stupid I remember
other weird ass core memory dude the
[__] full screen team building day
yeah yeah we went to Santa Monica the uh
the Park yeah and what the [__] is that
called
those like mountains
or that Park what's that called I don't
know but I remember we went there and
yeah yeah yeah right there pretty
awesome now but
that was that was really funny
so you so
you probably remember that Mike the CEO
of liquid death his wife was a senior
editor
oh and I think we were like semi-friends
uh what's I'll show you oh Carly yes
Carly yeah yes yeah yeah yeah isn't that
funny crazy so that's that's how
he even responded to me in the first
place when I just cold emailed him and
was like hey I love your brand I want to
invest and he was like dude small world
like my wife used to work with you full
screen and then uh he came on insanely
chill last week how was that it was good
it was fun I mean I I'm pretty new to
like actually having like a real like
business interview of course
it's hard to interview someone who
knows what the [__] they're doing and
you don't really yeah
so I mean it was like I definitely have
to like work on
you know being my question asking
capabilities whatever just asking like
smarter questions and stuff like that
but um
it was really fun yeah he's definitely
he's great he's like a super smart guy
yeah um
interesting story for sure because it's
like you know it's just a funny category
to be in water you know
and now everyone thinks it's satanic
and the double laps did you see that
Tick Tock uh which one the one of the
girl being like talking about like the
the uh structure of water molecules and
how there's a study done yeah where if
you said like negative words yeah for
the water it would change the structure
of the molecules yeah and apparently
that's been debunked yeah yeah it's like
not real yeah
it's pretty funny though